what is being an american to you
this is what being an american means to
me when i was a young
boy
i went
to my friend's
sister's house who was mentally [ __ ]
she was not diagnosed mentally [ __ ]
but she was incredibly dumb
we
she went out
she left us there
we said
she said to us do not leave
you can order dominoes and watch films
we said wouldn't it be funny if we left
a fake ransom note
for her she won't believe it she's not
that stupid
so we went to the park to smoke a pack
of cigarettes we had stolen from his
mother
and we left a ransom note that said i
kidnapped the two kids if you want them
back show up to this intersection with
money
well this [ __ ]
called the police because she actually
believed that we had been kidnapped and
she started hysterically crying and she
called the police
and we didn't know what to do
and we eventually walked back to the
house while the police were outside and
she was crying and she grabbed us and
hugged us
like she still thought that we had been
kidnapped
and she had called my friend's mother
and my friend's mother knew what was
going on and she was very angry
and she pulled out outside the house
and she looked at me and my friend and
she goes i can't believe you would do
this
to your sister and then she turned
around and she looked at the girl and
she went you are a [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's
what being an american means
to me
you see
everybody
has a different version
of the the joys
and the promises and the challenges of
this land
but that story
really encapsulates it
to me
i don't give a [ __ ] about disowning
property and any of that other [ __ ]
but when she looked at her and said you
are a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how stupid are you
i mean
it just made me happy and it was the
summer it was a nice
it was a nice summer memory but to me
america is about having an abortion with
a gun
it's about
eating a sandwich
that's made of a sandwich
it's about being on a boat getting
[ __ ] by a boat on a boat
it's about
hitting a dog
and unlike you not adopting it
driving on
that's what america is about to me
you know
it's about drinking gasoline
enlighten your inner fire
it's about crushing pills
on a cd case and snorting them to feel
good
it's about finding friends that you only
are friends with because they have drugs
it's about getting a job you hate in the
hopes that one day you could get a job
you hate that pays more money than this
one
it's about finding someone to [ __ ] who
hates you
being an american to me is about
traveling without truly ever leaving
never really appreciating anything
being handed stuff
getting a lot of things you don't
deserve and nothing you do
being handed things squandering
opportunities always attacking others
blaming
never being introspective and looking
down deep
in yourself as to why
uh you are where you are or how you
could have handled things better
being an american to me means being
entertaining at all times even when
killing someone
it means
that everything in life should be a
spectacle kind of an o.j simpson trial
everything
from your divorce to an argument at
breakfast everything should at all times
be insane
nothing should truly make sense outside
of the idea that it's all entertaining
and for sport
being an american to me means being
inconsiderate in a very considerate way
meaning
offending people
only once you've gotten to know them
pretty damn well
knowing the buttons to push and pushing
them
being an american to me means
figuring out that everything's full of
[ __ ] when you're about nine
and oscillating between drug food sex
addiction and the mismanagement of your
money to handle it
knowing at any time that your government
has orchestrated many different attempts
to kill and enslave you
and still enjoying top gun
it's a good film
being an american to me means never
feeling sorry for a feral cat
knowing that it'll figure it out just
like you will
being an american to me means looking at
a disabled person and knowing somewhere
down deep they deserve it
being an american to me
means you can summon up a murderous rage
at the slightest inconvenience
if someone refuses to seat you
in an appropriate period of time at a
restaurant
praying that they get into a car
accident where they bash their head off
their glove compartment and they live to
deal with the debt
being an american doesn't mean wishing
death on someone it means wishing
bankruptcy multiple times that they have
to go in and out of court it doesn't
mean wishing they lose their children it
means wishing they have to raise them
being being an american to me
means everything
and also nothing at all
we're a country of 350 million people
being an american means watching people
from all walks of life all corners of
the world come here and learn
to be a psychopath
being an american to me means being
jealous
vindictive petty hostile vicious
cowardly brave
also
being a liar
being a cynic
but being ultimately
hopeful
that one day the people you agree with
kill everyone else
being an american to me means concerning
yourself
with tunnels of children under the
ground
or government controlling the weather
but never
with your actual
position in life
and who's [ __ ] you that can actually
reach out and touch you
because they're out there
being an american to me
means understanding that tgif was a good
group of shows on abc and yes the kids
got raped
being an american to me means
understanding that wendy's in the 1990s
was maybe the greatest restaurant
that god
has ever given man
that the monterey ranch chicken sandwich
with bacon
in the ranch dressing
lettuce tomato
and a slice of monterey jack-ish like
cheese
on a soft bun
while eating
in a mazda navajo you had financed on
the way to a house you couldn't afford
but you had somehow figured out how to
pay for that month
was a great joy
america is a collection of minutes
it's a collection of cigarette breaks
it's a collection of finding a bathroom
in a mall
it's a collection of [ __ ]
it's a collection of lost friendships
unrequited loves opportunities you
didn't take
failures
small successes broken families
bitter horrible
nasty hopeless people that all come
together
every fourth of july to eat
that's what america is there's something
beautiful about it
america's industrial parks
our most beautiful places in america our
national parks
have become
playgrounds for killers
to murder people who go seek out their
majestic beauty
america means that the government may
kidnap your children and try to turn
them into sex slaves or assassins
mind control victims and brainwash them
but at the end of the day entenmann's is
a good cake
and everyone likes it
i do
america to me is about telling your
children to go to college
so that they can go
and haze other kids and kill them
that's what america means to me
america to me means you can start a
podcast with your friend
and end up on an fbi watch list
america to me means you can move to the
greatest city in america
austin texas
and live there
in a hundred degrees swampy
for a year
because it's
a truly moving experience
america means
the great comedy clubs the comedy store
the comedies
the stand and others
will be full of young children
and by young children i mean 41 year
olds
trying to make it as a buffoon
that's beautiful
america to me means that our one of our
most american sports golf
will like everything else
eventually be owned by the saudis
that's what america means to me it's a
great
country it's a beautiful place
i'm happy to be here but i would go
anywhere else
you understand
that's what america means to me
i've been incredibly blessed to live
here i've met some of the most
interesting people in my business and
other businesses
and i've realized that they're not
that interesting
and that's a blessing
that's a blessing
i've been i've met some of the
wealthiest people in the world some of
the most powerful people in the world
and i'll tell you right now there's
nothing more fun than doing cocaine with
your friend in the back of a rental car
that's america to me
america to me
comes down to three words
shut your mouth
[Laughter]
shut your mouth because someone else is
talking
and that person is smarter than you or
at least they've robbed more people
america to me is about endless
options
for pancakes
so many different types of fluffy
pancakes that you can put your head on
and sleep
america to me is about the chalky taste
that a pharmaceutical leaves as it
slides down your throat
headed to your bloodstream to make it
all better
america means finding your child oh deed
in the bathroom
[Laughter]
getting the narcan out
and reviving them
so they live to rob you one more time
that's what america means
never give up
never surrender
we have a beautiful
and very very disgusting country
and i'm proud to live here
i'm proud of all of our problems
our school shootings are tent cities
they
are our greatest strengths
it's all a matter of perspective
that's what america means to me
america means to me
sitting at a bar
next to someone
and i've done this
where you're doing shots
and their child
their 11 year old child walks in
crying
and says daddy please come home
and he goes you're not old enough to be
in here
you have to leave
okay little angel
daddy will be home soon
and then the mother comes in
and she goes how can you sit there as a
man
while your daughter cries
and asks for you to come home
and he says [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my
face
and she leaves
and then he looks at me and he goes
she's very selfish
and i said i think she is
and he goes would you like to split an
order of clams
that's what america means to me
what a selfish [ __ ]
whatever america means to you out there
i don't care
doesn't mean anything to me
all i ask is that you keep listening to
our show and keep paying us
whatever else you do
whatever genocides you commit
just know
that all we care about
is that you support us
you can beat your wife
you can torture your children
you could be like jenny's dad in forrest
gump just rape them all
but if you buy our products
if you buy tickets to see me
and you support our patreon
like they say in the opening scene of
the wire it's america man
it's america
so
with all of that
our show is exclusively moving
to saudi spotify
it will be available
only in the country of saudi arabia
and they're giving us a hundred
million
dollars
the most american thing i could think of
to do
would be to sell this podcast
to saudi arabia
the most american thing i could do would
be to open this podcast next week
sitting in full saudi garb
from a palace in riyadh
and don't think i won't do it
don't think for a minute
that i won't do it oh christ i'll do it
that is the most american thing
that i can do
it's the most american thing i can do
it's really the most american thing i
can do
because it's um
it's a country about the future
it's not about the past
it's not about oh the government did 9
11. it's what are they going to do next
it's about the future you can't
lose yourself
you have to
always focus on the great things
that are coming our way
my father said something to me
that was very brilliant
and it meant a lot to me
we were driving once
and he said to me he said son
never overestimate your worth
he said you're not that special
and anything you can do someone else can
probably do
and i always remember that
i always remember that
i think it made a lot of sense
he said to me one day me and your mother
it's not that we don't love each other
it's that we don't love each other
anymore
we're
we're ending this marriage
you know
listen i don't it's no secret that i
don't speak to a lot of my family and
that's okay that doesn't mean much
doesn't mean anything
you know
but that's what america is
america is about
family america is about family
that's what america is about it's a big
we're a big wacky family
we're a big wacky family
and my mother
has always been
you know pretty honest with me
about this country
she's she's always been honest she said
to me you're too fat to be on television
consistently
she said if you dye your hair
someone may give you enough money to fix
your teeth
and she said barack obama's a muslim
now
my mother's a great american story
because she started out
as a wiki watching mermaid in florida
she spent years as a surfer
then having me and then was a swim
teacher
and now
she ends as a paranoid schizophrenic
locked away in a room
but if we only knew about live streaming
ma
oh god
the money you could have made
the money ma could have made
if we just knew about live streaming
because
man mommy would have [ __ ] lit up
those super chats
mommy would have live streamed her way
right out
let's question the timing
question of timing
it's unfortunate do you have anything to
add before we get out of here no that
was beautiful yes absolutely beautiful
it's almost like i'm the one that should
talk
this guy took him in homeownership he
doesn't own anything
he owns a sick dog kill it
everyone i hope you enjoy
uh your fourth of july
i hope you remember
what made this country great
fraud
murder
and cool [ __ ]
cool [ __ ]
we've got cool [ __ ] here got cool [ __ ]
people come here they go that's pretty
cool
be
cool
smoke drink use drugs
make a lot of money
die very young
[Laughter]
kill others